there's a spaceport 20 miles south we'll
be able to board a galaxy-class cruise
ship and jump through a wormhole that
will put us within spitting distance of
the Milky Way but hey it's about the
journey not the destination right Jerry
everybody knew Rick and Morty was
probably one of the best episodes of the
season so far and it was a Jerry episode
who apparently really wishes that he had
a vagina but there's a new round of that
merch giveaway for Zen monkey studios
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
so the episode wasn't a direct parity of
any other big property like the way they
did comic book movies for last week's
episode but there was a lot of attack on
Titan there was a lot of Jeff Goldblum
movies that they did so let's just go to
the episode from beginning to end
the opening scene may have seemed very
familiar it's almost an exact copy of
the opening scene from the pilot episode
Morty come on Rick what's going on a
surprise for you midnight what are you
talking about I got a surprise for you
come on hurry up gotta go gotta get out
your tuck it fought too hard when they
first entered the resort they pass by
the same bullets and chips alien that
also appeared in last week's episode so
we'll see if he keeps popping up maybe
they stick them in every single episode
this season but right off the bat they
start with a couple Jeff Goldblum
references where Rick says hey what's up
Big Chill don't get into that telepods
and turns around and it's Jeff Goldblum
looking all disfigured like when he got
out of the telepods in the fly most of
you probably got the fly reference but
the Big Chill if you haven't seen it is
just one of the earlier movies that he
did but we learned that Jerry secretly
thought about having a vagina once he
goes into the bathroom the stoles and
the sinks kind of look like vaginas when
summer gets all worked up about big
stripper titties she starts rifling
through Rick's belongings one of the
devices she pulls out is made to look
like a flux capacitor from Back to the
Future and then we finally learned that
the world leaderly conspiracy is just a
literal description of the episode in
one of the big make up ends the world
leader Lee is a big roller coaster
that's painted to look like the Mach 5
racer from Speed Racer in the track kind
of looks like a tooth if you ever saw
the original animated series or even the
live-action movie that they did this is
kind of how the cars move around the
track but they jump around
it's really crazy you may have
recognized the voice of the person
trying to get rid of Rick it's actually
Clancy Brown he just has that very
identifiable deep booming voice but he
plays mr. Krabs on SpongeBob SquarePants
he's been on almost every single cartoon
series in the last ten to twenty years
it's required somebody with a deep
booming voice like that last week was of
a comic book episode but Clancy Brown is
also doing the voice for fire Lord sir
one of the big villains for Thor
Ragnarok so you just have to imagine
this booming voice coming out of this
giant fire demon but Rick has all kinds
of Jerry burns
20 cc's of liquid dream killer what a
way to describe teenage pregnancy it's
okay to be mistrustful of Rick when he
comes around on Jerry like you always
wonder if there's something else behind
it is he just playing Jerry and making
him think that he's taking it easy on
him because the end of the episode he
does invite him in and Jerry's like no
no no but we learn when they go through
customs that he has mostly cybernetic
parts so it's probably not even the real
version of c-137 rig you guys can let me
know the title of the episode was all
about conspiracy actual Rick and Morty
episode conspiracy who is this version
of Rick we just have to assume that it's
happening in a different reality or rick
has somehow substituted cybernetic rick
for himself and he's off doing something
else there were all kinds of Easter eggs
during the beth morty summer plot Beth
says summer Clive Barker herself she's
talking about the Cenobites from the
Hellraiser series would they basically
turn people skin inside out they look
like they have their skin turned inside
out it's pretty horrific but the actual
character model is made to look like the
colossal Titan on attack on Titan that's
why when they're looking over the trees
down on Ethan here when she starts
freaking out on him before Beth runs in
that's sort of there we can attack on
Titan totally not fazed by it the little
girl there looks at them with their
inside-out skin it says I need to go
call my mother just because it's such a
touching moment but then back during the
Rick plot when they're getting ready to
go through the wormhole it's a little
bit 2001 Space Odyssey when he's slowly
evolving into the star child but the way
they animate it makes it look a little
bit like the heavy-metal animated movie
if you've ever seen that and there were
a couple other parts that looks familiar
I couldn't quite put my finger on but
there were so many animated series
influences that happened in this if you
spotted some specific ones just write
them below in the comments but that's
sort of what this is meant to be the
animated version of the 2001 Space
Odyssey sequence of all the trippy
scenes during this there was the one
where Rick is wrestling around with
Jerry that might be a reference to
Jerry's tendencies remember the sleepy
time Gary episode that's all there
inside him and then there was the
version of Rick that was nursing that
little alien on the fireplace mantel in
the background here you see a little
bird person and you see a little bust of
Beth probably the creepiest most
nightmare-inducing version of Rick that
we've seen so far in the multiverse let
me know in the comments though after
seeing this what is the most horrifying
version of Rick that we've seen so far
but the end tag isn't so much of an
easter egg because it's just meant to be
a really funny moment where we learned
that Morty has done the David Cronenberg
fly thing to Ethan in revenge for what
he did to summer so they bring it all
the way back around a Jeff Goldblum
which is another callback to Cronenberg
world which is the c-137 universe that
we've revisited again during episode 1
they keep going back to Cronenberg so I
guess that summer's Geena Davis in this
equation maybe she either finishes Ethan
off flies style David Cronenberg or he
goes to live on Cronenberg world if you
haven't seen the end of the fly is
really freaky probably one of the best
80s horror sci-fi films but if he did
spot any other Easter eggs or references
in the episode that I didn't include in
the video just write them below in the
comments and let me know what was your
favorite moment and let me know what's
your favorite episode of season 3 so far
I don't know if this is my favorite but
I do feel like the story was a lot
stronger the characters were a lot
better especially the B plot with what
was happening with summer because as
crazy as she was like she wanted to give
herself big stripper titties it was a
plot that had nothing to do with Rick or
Morty she just had this thing in her
head that she was going to take care of
herself and it causes Morty to have to
get involved to try and fix it because
his mom isn't being his mom so Morty
winds up having to step up and be the
parent in this episode this is sort of
the comedy version of what happens when
parents get divorced like to get super
irresponsible like oh I'm going to take
some me time she gets all obsessed with
those horse hooves and needs a big win I
need this Morty Mama's coming baby
Mama's company she cares about your
kitty so even if you don't really like
their using the divorce is a big running
plot point I feel like they've had some
really interesting character moments
this episode in particular I think just
worked a lot better too in one of the
really fun things now too is to see what
the writers have to say about some of
the jokes in the episode or just things
in general like you know what I wasn't
really sure about the ball slapping I
fought against it and I'm glad I lost it
totally worked so I think I may have
said this in a previous video but a lot
of times they'll have things like this
that they work in in subtle ways this is
obviously very obvious like you
definitely see Jerry getting slapped in
the face with a giant ball sack but if
you look really carefully in season 1
and season 2 episodes you can spot a lot
of sex organs like even in episode 1 the
spaceships is there taking off it took
somebody a long time to animate that
giant ship so if you have a friend
that's never seen Rick and Morty and you
want to troll them just a little bit
show them one of these episodes and see
if they pick up on it immediately so
what will happen is I'll do a video for
the next episode tomorrow along with my
Game of Thrones Q&A congratulations to
the latest merch giveaway winner Timothy
Wong please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details while you wait for
everything click here for all my Rick
and Morty episode videos and you can
click here for the trailer for the Game
of Thrones finale thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]